hello everybody my name is Mark Larne
welcome to zoms IO or Zambia SunZia some
visio this one was interesting because
supposedly and again I don't know I'm
talking to my ass here I don't really
know
start off by gathering some resources
but supposedly really give it to this
tree here but supposedly this one is
different because you actually build a
base here and you got to build it and
try to survive against a zombie attack
so I don't know what that means in the
long run but hopefully it's gonna mean
something okay once you're now you're
ready to place down your gold stash once
you establish your base zombies will
start spawning each night whoo oh damn
okay I don't know if I'm ready no maybe
I should get more supplies gold stash
okay we're gonna do this right Oh Jenna
okay I'll standing on that one sorry ha
you're ready to start building your
defenses start by using five wood and
gathered in place an arrow tower from
toolbar below okey-dokey then
oh okay oh hi I didn't know I wasn't
ready for sales I was not ready oh god
okay all right all right oh right oh
right okay okay okay okay okay
gold mine I don't know it Oh gold mine
okay all right
I don't know how I got dad but okay
cannon tower I don't have wood or stone
but I can build more gold mines which is
always a good guess I have no idea what
I'm doing I probably shouldn't have
space everything out like this now that
I'm thinking about it but well I'm
getting gold I think I'm trapped
wait I've just [ __ ] myself I have
bones owned myself I can't move I boxed
myself in I'm an [ __ ] let me try this
again them job no we're gonna arrive
again oh those guys are on wave 100
they're pretty good at whatever they do
but I don't know if they've met me and
how good I am at slapping this tree with
this bush with my rock stick B I'm good
at hit rock stick oh yeah I don't need
to worry about night I don't even have a
base belt so I don't think I'm left
I'm just gonna stay here and build as
best I can
hopefully it's okay I don't know if it
will be but I have got hope in my heart
and that's usually what powers me
through these adventures even in the
face of death of zombie bite I'm gonna
be fine believe myself okay I think
that's probably enough okay I'm going to
be old dears now and I'm not going to be
so stupid about it I'm going to build on
a building's actually a bit more out
that way I least have some equidistance
old room to build those then I can fill
these right there that's good I bet
there's a way to unbuild if there's a
way to build there's got to be a way to
unveil doing ping pong okay I got those
I don't know if that step for me but I
got it woo that's what I spend my go oh
that makes sense yeah okay alright
that's beta I don't want to do any of
that I like to do it myself maybe I'm
gonna get another pickaxe alright up
Graham a pickaxe boiling point point
point to you doubles
i likey I'm like who are you get out of
here you know you're not a good player I
don't need a not a good player in my
area I need a good player maybe I don't
know how you would help me or any
capacity die ooh death to you oh I I
have I have a bit of a problem here
oh oh oh boy oh boy I didn't anticipate
them coming from who ah I am bones they
get my [ __ ] oh they bashed up my gold
mines farming things oh hey I'm on the
leaderboard
hey really low on the leaderboard but
Liam bear up now up just drop the spot
okay um
the bottom nevermind I'm not on the
leaderboard at 15 I don't know the
band's
we're gonna have a lot of Bam's walls
would be smart why don't I have walls
that seems like something that I need I
don't know if that helps me in any way
or if they're evil men are they even
able to hit through that the fasces pero
la ola okay they can't fire over the
wall that's good to know
hey hey come on now come on silly Jim
get out of there well I mean I'm doing
something can I upgrade these then the
last thing I know you can okay so I need
stain why are you not go faster go
faster get that stone get it dirty grab
it with your claw oh I'm an upgrade you
bad boys what can I not upgrade you bad
girls you seem like something that I
would be able to upgrade you bad boys
you bad boys why are you not afraid
about this is a load of [ __ ] I am
quest
doodlee doodlee doodlee doodlee doing
okay got that good I didn't build a door
but I don't can't even build the core
gonna do report give me your [ __ ] refuel
I don't know what that's gonna do oh hey
we got incoming
we I ain't coming good okay don't take
my gold you got I just because I've got
to build something doesn't mean that you
get to jump in there who you have
weapons why do you have weapons hey hey
hey hey eat a bunch of pickaxe in the
face you fool I asked okay there's this
door work that's how that work I don't
know if that how that work I play stores
and hopefully that's okay yes okay
something that I can go through I don't
know why I didn't build it on the
outside of these towers here but maybe
it's because again I'm stupid and I
don't know what I'm doing so I've got
kind of a little bit of a base here
because I'm going to christen it as
castle markiplier is stupid I'm going to
call it the market castle because I'm
unoriginal and I'm egotistical and I
like the sound of my own name doodly-doo
doodly-doo whacking at a tree until I
get a lot of wood now school leading
dearly to earn this tree up real good
now hey [ __ ] you get away from my base
don't you dare come over here I'm going
to go through my door I can't upgrade
anything walking on up I don't know why
life is alive Oh upgrade
that oh oh I can upgrade everything else
now made you refuel you repeal real good
okay so the most important thing is to
upgrade as you go I'm starting to get
bang if this I get it I love tower
defense games I love just base building
stuff even if it's mundane like this now
I don't know how it applies when
everyone else is involved in the game
here because there are a lot of people
errand marking move it's not the only
one I'm server but I'm gonna preview
bellboys so I've been lying don't click
these bad boys for a while oh you bad
boys a pretty you - oh you bad boys oh I
need more gold hey you upgraded bad boys
you make more gold now okay come on you
make more gold faster oh those look so
good huh things look a little damaged
but that's okay I got my melee towers
they are the ones that are really gonna
give it to them that's a good bad boy
these are good bad boys here there's a
lot of good bad boy going on here
upgrade upgrade upgrade upgrade upgrade
upgrade Annan's upgrade upgrade suite
nah none up wood oh jeez these walls
ain't I gotta upgrade all these walls
all were you kidding me I'm gonna do it
but I'm gonna be angry about it oh we're
gonna [ __ ] the kind of [ __ ] that I gotta
deal with Oh as if they don't know who I
am right now that I've slapped gold
inside my walls they're definitely
aren't going to be people to come out
and kill me well so they don't seem like
zombies they're using weapons and seem
awfully intelligent and organized and I
mean they may be coming knocking at my
door dingdong at night but that doesn't
mean that they're not super smart about
what they're doing
swings wrong oh that is a lot of those
[ __ ] what am I what did barely on
number seven oh god I'm on leaderboard
now but I apparently I'm not going to
stay there because ever one thing is
going horribly wrong I'm guessing that I
should be a lot more upgraded than I
actually am right now maybe I should
make double thick walls that seems like
something that I should do well now that
I got some wood stop swinging stop it
stop why are you swinging so much what
do you got so swing for like this pain
don't you know that the end with zombies
until you die I'm going to build more
walls cuz why not oh they broke through
oh well that's a damn shame
alright well plug that hole up real good
I don't think I got enough to upgrade
all these bad boys but hey you know
what's probably good enough to repel
evil zombie
Jack I mean well sold that one didn't
mean to but all right here we go there
we go that's good you don't need to be
there all right cool I'm a build more
doors
I like good ok well that looks bad but I
guess it's gonna have to do right do
have enough to upgrade this I sure do
all right I did that now glad there was
a klaxon horn that was making that all
sound really authentic and cool we did
that now I'm getting more gold so
exponential growth is good I good either
way I'm gonna keep hitting this rock
because that's the first thing I did
when I came into this world so I see
last thing I want to do when I get
dragged out kicking screaming by zombie
night game soon like winter have I died
yet am i dead is everything dead yeah
probably
I'm gonna go with probably number 6 on
leaderboard the other people are still
up in the millions but at least I'm
making a good school
oh hi who the [ __ ] are you I thought you
were an enemy real quick oh my god I've
got a whole bunch of other people here
why are they here I don't know what do
you want to do with me hey get out of
here what's that hey you [ __ ] you're
a ball come on to me
hey [ __ ] you what are you doing yeah you
better back off yeah that's right he's
dead now I think I killed him that's
what you get for smick smack in my wall
don't do that is the lesson you learn
don'ts make smack we don't belong and
then you won't be dead did understood
and I made myself absolutely not clear
hey what are you doing in fact did you
get out of here
I'm enjoying my okay well you got buzz
coming your way for summary I don't know
why but you do you really do hey Dom
what do ya is that a boss not a big boss
oh god get away from my gold hey hey
no no no no no no no no no get dead Oh
got it oh god he's gettin my stash not
my stash No
that's what he was waiting for oh no
he's dead - okay well alright then
alright respawn Oh
I'm swinging I'm swinging back into life
okay well I guess I'm back now I thought
that was gonna be the end of it but I
did go - bound at the beginning zone
that is the thing that happens okay why
I'm gonna go and see if there's other
players around everywhere oh the
infected ask to join me I didn't even
see that in the chat because my face was
covering it
oops oopsy poopsy that was my bad oopsie
oh I could have gone on expeditions I
could have bought a sperg gonna bought a
sweet spur and then smack you in the
foot no damaged and not get I could have
bought more all that would have been
great - no I didn't know that all
there's more complexity to this game
whose job I'm just okay I don't know
what happened
Oh dog well this is broken
okay no no I am broke the game nice
approach and got to stab my way back to
my basic stabbed get stabbed you want to
do they got give me anything oh they
give me tokens I don't know what to do
with tokens but at least those are a
thing can get stabbed
watch the goose-girl Street it's death
Rockets can do you got my basil you get
stabbed it's dead but are the double air
walls work to him all these guys got
stabbed into oblivion they didn't see
this Abaddon's coming okay all right we
got pretty good operation going on here
I'm pretty proud of this everyone's done
a great job here there's no one here but
you know someone has to be my friend and
then I forgotten
I said no apparently I'm an a-hole so
anyway that has been I'm stuck okay
there we go
alright we're I don't think that's
working correctly I'm lagging a bit here
but that is zombie oh so that was pretty
fun I actually enjoyed that a bit I can
see if this was a more populated server
and I would stop jumping all over the
place this could be a lot of fun if it
was super super scoop or dense so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this one there's
numerous other io games in
website alone there's just I can even
show you the home page here if I leave
my thing
there's just guard akio wild deal flappy
a blocker game cuz app go eat bomb hi
squad dark Nova spin vo I don't want
Evan want to go near that one and then
MooMoo IO which I've heard also was a
good one stress so if you know any of
these the floor is lava anyway so
there's a whole bunch of other ones here
if you guys want to see any of these
played let me know there's just tons and
tons of these so go to this website if
you want play some free multiplayer
games thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know you thought it down
the comments below thanks Han for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
buh-bye here
[Music]